relax
[Music]
let go of describing your experience
relax
[Music]
use your breath
[Music]
hey
take that very relaxed
vibe
and be vigilant about maintaining
that very relaxed vibe
as we continue through this
show
and leverage your breath as a tool
to bring you back to this very
relaxed peaceful
and joyful state throughout
your days
earlier today
i posted almost 40.
of these graphics
to instagram and
as these
little aphorisms
and laconic
compressed distillations
of our nature come through like this
i will create an accompanying
video like this
where we further unpack
the graphics in more detail
as you can tell this one is titled
avoid void
which is another way to say infinity and
nothingness
which is what the mystic traditions have
pointed to
for millennia about the nature
of reality
and it is currently at the center
of the graphics as you can see which we
will
get to unpacking that in more detail
so we'll go ahead and we'll start
unpacking these graphics which
in essence are
like we've been doing in the direct path
videos on our channel
all we are doing is pointing
to the same one end
from the different faces
we're just dressing it up differently
we're saying it in a different way
and it's all to help the confused
seeker recognize
their true nature
so in this graphic we say you
cannot hide from me
you are me
you are inescapable divinity
in this case what we mean when we say
the capital m me
or when you say the capital s
self we are referring
to god we are referring to
the absolute we are referring to source
we are referring to dao we are referring
to brahman
so you cannot hide from
me as in you are already
me you are already
the absolute you are always
already free
that is your true nature
this
is the absolute
and yet it is up to you
to recognize it
and typically what happens to those that
don't
recognize it is
that the mind toils them
around from suffering to suffering they
get
intoxicated by maya by the illusion
by lakshmi with a fishing line
drawing them around from experience to
substance to relationship
trying to extract peace and happiness
from the world
rather than recognizing that they're
very
nature is peace
and happiness
which is why the roomy quote goes you go
from room to room looking for the
diamond that is
already around your neck
you cannot hide from me you
are me
you are inescapable divinity
everything is unconditional
celebration
can you really let that become your
vibration
can you let that become the radiance
can you become the sun
endlessly effortlessly
emanating love light
peace warmth joy bliss
prosperity wellness abundance
can you let that very
relaxed state
the very peaceful joyful
dancing state become
your baseline become your norm
that is what we mean when we say natural
state and so that very
unconditional celebration
is exactly what the noisy mind
prevents people from hearing
that very unconditional celebration is
the music it's the very background
nectar it's the very undercurrent
of unity
but if the mind is noisy
i gotta do this i can do that
i'm feeling so depressed i'm feeling so
anxious
i gotta run to this thing i gotta run to
that thing i gotta i don't know if i'm
gonna make it on time i have to pay for
this i have to pay for that
oh my god i have that calendar
appointment in a week i don't know if
i'm gonna get on a vacation this year i
don't have to pay for insurance right
now oh my god
i'm not another red light oh my gosh
that person cut me off
that is the noisy mind
see the difference
relaxation
peace joy
bliss
versus anxiety and being toiled
around incessantly
by the mind that
mind that's being toiled around will
never hear
that sweet omnipresent
nectar background music that's always
present
it's always here
it's the very undercurrent of
existence of reality
of the natural state is the
unconditional celebration
and we have to recognize that
when you have these many different
layers
in understanding the nature of reality
you have
both the this is the absolute
you're already the absolute you're
already it you're already enlightened
and yet when somebody's experiencing
that state of the noisy mind
this is what we typically call stream
entry is necessary this is what is
needed
in order for somebody to recognize their
true
blissful peaceful enlightened already
nature
is to become the witness
become the observer become the subtle
awareness
in which the clouds of thoughts
and emotions and beliefs and perceptions
and sensations
appear and disappear
and so to get to that stage when you're
in the very noisy mind
there is a gym repetition
to do
and the gym repetition is to become more
and more
subtly aware of awareness itself
oh following a thought cloud boop back
to the sky
back to awareness following another
emotional cloud boop back to the sky
back to awareness leverage the breath
and as you do that more and more often
you will recognize
you will recognize
that this is the unconditional
celebration already
ever present and free and creative
and
[Music]
but when you're in the state of the
noisy mind it sounds like
totally playing out of tune in the
symphony
these beautiful 8 billion
units in the symphony on this planet
are yet it's very clear
that there are those being toiled by
mind and there are those that are very
and so those are the gym repetitions is
to move
closer and closer towards the
unconditional celebration that you
already are yet it remains for you to
recognize it
so this is where simultaneity is really
mission critical
where you have both of those at the same
time
which is that there's nothing to seek
because you are already
it the absolute and yet at the same time
there is something to seek
which is these gym repetitions to become
more and more subtly
aware of awareness itself
rather than being toiled by the mind
and then you recognize that awareness is
shared
and awareness is eternal and that i
am the source that even uses awareness
as its first attribute in order to
experience
reality
complete surrender to the divine
unfolding of the perfection we already
are
so relaxation
is another way to talk about
surrender
when you take a macro level view
of the planet and of the
evolution and the very natural secretion
of the 10 million existing species
on the planet
you take that macro level view and you
see a very
surrendered divine secretion
unfolding of the planetary evolution
we are that that is
humans and so now you see the difference
between when you're vibrating at the um
you're like a flower effortlessly
blossoming towards the sun
versus when you were in the
when the mind is toiling you around
that is very
non-harmonic that is very distorted
that is very twisted that has a layer
of attachment to
the identity to the form to the
separation
to maya seeking peace and happiness from
the world
the very nature of most of the mind
toiling that very
suffering
can be healed
can have a shift into
alignment
by doing those gym repetitions of
becoming more and more subtly aware
of awareness itself leveraging the
breath
which the mystics and the yogis
have talked about for millennia
leverage the breath
as patanjali said union with god or the
absolute is simply the cessation
of the fluctuations of mind
take that very mind toiling
and leverage the breath
to have that cessation of the
fluctuations of mind
and then you become more relaxed and
then this
surrender to the very divine unfolding
of the perfection becomes the natural
baselined state
it's that simple you're
already it if you know your true
nature you are effortlessly harmonically
aligned by knowing your true nature
you know that these other costumes
of these eight billion total units on
this planet
are you you know that the one
intelligence is all of these costumes
therefore you know as the one
intelligence
that the other costumes are you
therefore when you know yourself you do
not commit malevolence
therefore you know that the optimal
is to be in service to others
because you are in service to yourself
and we work on that process in purifying
where we're coming from
so that we refine
our ability to be in true service
and that we refine all of those
onion layers that we were previously
attached to
form an identity an ego
extracting peace and happiness from maya
and we work on the purifying
so that we no longer have those
distortions and twists
and therefore we are completely aligned
with that one infinite creator
the very nature of our reality
and become in service to others
in this ascensionary process
so as we were doing
at the beginning
and hopefully throughout
not only the show but throughout your
days
leveraging the breath
for a few seconds drop
all attributes drop
describing your experience drop
symbolization itself when you have the
absolute absence of symbolization
of describing and of attributes
what is left simply
your very naked nature
which is i am
the very fact that i am
just like in exodus 3 14
i am that i am
is god the very
naked nature is
god you are
that and then we add
all these layers to our onion
and become attached and identified with
them
and that's where all of the kinks the
twists
the distortions
arise and we become attached to them and
our whole identity becomes
about other costumes validating
our layers of
onion
even the atlas costume
on a daily basis goes through the
process
of continuing to refine
and purify
where he's coming from
to truly know oneself
is to be hyper vigilant about every
single frame of one's existence
are you coming from a place of a
distortion
or a twist or a kink in that i
am where you're filling
the need for a self
gratification
that i need someone to validate me
i am currently judging
that somebody else has
something that i don't have
rather than beautifully accepting
that firework exactly as it is and
beautifully accepting your own firework
exactly as it is
go back to the very process of relaxing
over and over again during your day
as these gym repetitions relaxing
your perspective your point of view
leveraging the breath
to sink inward in
word inward become hyper aware
of consciousness of awareness of
observation of witnessing
itself and as you do that
you will recognize the i am
the very fact that you are
naked is god that is god
then all of these additional layers of
identity and distortion and twist
peel them back
peel them back
hit
[Music]
[ __ ] this puzzle is hard what
is i
ah yes
all is love light leela
this is a fun graphic it's another way
to
describe the parable of the prodigal son
it's very cute
when you can reflect on
the process the trajectory the journey
the dance where
you so ignorantly were
in this puzzle the very puzzleless
puzzle the very lockless
escape room
ah this is so hard what do i do how do i
find
peace and happiness
do i find it from nine to five job
do i find it from 30-year mortgage
obviously no and so that's the parable
of the prodigal son
when as you're trying to extract peace
and happiness from substances and
experiences and relationships
i will find a significant other and they
will make
me happy sounds pretty ridiculous
right
you hit a breaking point suffering
catalyzes it it's the drill sergeant of
awakening
it's one of our best tools that we use
ego suffering this
best tool we use to actually create this
turn inward
from those onion layers inward and
as we go inward the top question that we
ask
is what is i
what is i
and as we do this process
the very self-inquiry itself
that enables us to dissolve
said egoic layers to the onion
as we go inward to the very
formlessness of awareness
consciousness witnessing observation
itself
very similar to saint francis of assisi
that which you seek
is the seer
you are seeking the seer
itself
become more and more subtly aware of
these very
profound metaphysical truths
they are your rare candies
they are your ways to go
super saiyan
become more subtly aware of you
are seeking the seer and
do the gym repetitions to become more
and more subtly aware
of awareness of consciousness of
observation of witnessing
itself
and you'll become more and more subtly
aware that the very nature of that
awareness
is peace and joy
and you stop trying to extract it from
the world and rather you become more
and more like the sun
which is why when you come to the
revelation ah
yes you recognize your true nature
that is when you remember all
is love light leela i
am the one infinite creator i am the one
intelligence i am
source i am god i am brahmana i am dao
and all of this is my love light
leela lila
sanskrit for the divine play
this is all the very divine play of
my love light in this
planetary ascensionary dream with 8
billion
units in a civilization
figuring out how to maximize their
potential
i dig many holes then dig myself
out all holes and digging
are illusion i am funny
he he
as you remember we mentioned earlier
the very lockless
escape room
that is analogous to this hole
so i dig the one infinite crater
through all of these costumes digs all
of these
holes for itself aka
the lockless escape rooms
and then we dig ourselves
out
aka unlock
the lockless locks of that set escape
room
and in that process we
recognize that the very holes
and digging was an illusion
that the whole time we
were always already free
and that's why we're so funny
the nature of reality is hilarious
and this was on another recent post we
made
that you're on an endless river and
the river is an illusion
you're [ __ ] hilarious
again that's trying to signal the very
nothingness and infinitude
simultaneously
i bet i can't do a creation where i
forget
so intensely that i kill 100 million
people in 100 years bet
boom when you look at the 20th century
that was our will
that was our choice
our very decision
in this dreamed creationary ascension
to experience what it is like where we
forget our true nature so intensely
that we kill a hundred million
people
a hundred million of our own costumes
we forgot that intensely
and this is where the quotes come when
the roots reach hell
the branches the fruits can reach
heaven
the ascent and the descent happened
simultaneously
around 1945 you get both the nuclear
weapon
and you get lsd
in 2008 you get the financial
recession and you get
bitcoin and decentralization
we are the creators we
are that which
made the decision to experience
the very catastrophic 20th century
we are also the creators of the 21st
century we are the very
creators of the 2020s themselves
where we can amplify the things that
maximize human potential that
enable the maximal fireworking of every
single one
of our unique expressions of
infinity
and that is what pure service to others
is
is when you're truly trying from a very
pure place
to maximize the potential of
civilization
and then think creatively what's next
we've come from eternity and eternity is
where we're continuing to go
what other crazy cool fun
forgetful intense creations will we
design
with completely different vehicles of
awareness
with completely different civilizational
dynamics
with completely different universes that
may not even be
planets orbiting stars
may not even be physics math
biology the code of life that we have
completely radically different it may
not be
a three space with one time
architecturally
the possibilities are limitless
that's your true nature you are the
source
of infinite possibility that is your
true nature
and when you know that joy and peace
sets in that is the natural state
we all of the endless possibilities
we what
is enlightenment the infinite fountain
of bliss that you
already are as we just described
once you unlock the lockless
lock you recognize
that i've been the infinite fountain of
bliss
this whole time
it was just obscured by this very
toiling
mind
that was perpetuating my suffering
by having me seek peace and happiness
externally
rather than turn inward to recognize the
nature of awareness itself
occasionally clap once
loudly
deepen awareness of the
now and stretch it out to the
entire universe
this is ineffable perfection
again a very simple activity
occasionally clap once loudly and as you
do
tap in to the now
at a deeper level and stretch out
that ineffable perfection to the whole
universe
so clap and then watch that
reverberation
at the level of the universe ineffable
perfection after
ineffable perfection after ineffable
perfection
leverage activities like that
they're really fun and they really help
the deepening and the abiding
it's pretty fun to make definitions
we can use symbolization
to help us better directly
point to our true nature and more
easily help other costumes
with their confusion and their
seeking to fulfill it
by doing said process of defining
spirituality
as realignment
with the one heart
one's very ability to go
from the mind
toiling seeking peace and happiness
externally attachment
to these onion layers of identity
and form and validation
and to be able to recognize that
the very process of
the cessation of the fluctuations
of the toiling mind enable
me to become more and more aware of
awareness itself
which then very
effortlessly makes me aware
of the diamond that was already around
my neck
the well of honey that was covered by
this rockless
rock and then
i feel that well of honey of
peace and joy spirituality
is realigning oneself to the
already present peace and
joy it's
the realigning to the very
knowledge that i am the creator
that all of these costumes are my
very creation and that
all is my love light that is at play
there is no unsafety there is no
victimhood that is just the toiling
mind that is making the distorted
declarations that it is unsafe
that
it needs validation that it has
lack that it needs peace and happiness
from
a watch or from a 30-year mortgage or
from a relationship
or a substance
spirituality is the ultimate script
the ultimate algorithm the ultimate
process that transcends all of those
other sticky processes
that then enables one to undergo the
process of
that game changing final
realignment to the true nature and then
become in pure service
aligned with god's love light leela
feeling the radiant warmth
of the sun peace and joy
and butterflying that out to all
costumes
and that's why it's the one heart
it's the one intelligence
and that's what spirituality is
i am that which is constantly in
delusion
about my unity
i am the one infinite creator i am
source i am god's love light that is at
play in perpetual delusion
of my own true unity
when the mind is toiling us around in
those egoic
onion layer seeking peace and happiness
externally is that not
absolute delusion
and so that very process
of endless forgetting
to remember of endless hide
and seek that very endless
process of venturing outward hitting the
wall like in the parable of the prodigal
son
catalyzed by suffering as the drill
sergeant of awakening
the forcing function to turn inward to
become aware of awareness itself
as peace and joy and become aware of
oneself as the creator of
awareness and of the reality that very
process
is the nature of reality but you are
beyond
the coming and going you are beyond the
birth and death you are beyond the
nothingness and the infinitude
you are
this indescribable
perfection
i am that which vibrates between
void and infinity
that very nothingness void
shunya
and the very infinite eternal
fire working individuation endless
form endless costumes endless realities
endless creations endless leela
you are that which is the
um vibratory
between that
that is you you are the nothing you are
the everything you
flow in between both and you are
beyond that
i am that which is a creative
forcing function between void and
infinity
the very nature of you as
source is infinite possibility
that is your very nature
you are infinite possibility if you
truly
knew what eternity was if you truly
knew what infinity was if you truly knew
that
you would relax into the peace and joy
of being agnostic being
of knowing that truly
but when you don't know eternity when
you don't know infinity when you don't
know yourself
as that the source of infinite
possibilities the very
creative forcing function that endlessly
gives rise to these
gorgeous realities of love light lila
with
all of these unique forms and unique
costumes at play with itself
when you don't know that that's when the
mind
toils you around incessantly
know thyself on the top
of the temple of apollo at delphi the
number one delphic maxim two words
know thyself know thyself
know thyself know thyself
as the source of infinite possibility
know self as the very creative forcing
function between that nothingness and
everythingness
you are that
avoid void
when you put an a in front of void
it's the opposite of void what's the
opposite of void what's the opposite of
nothingness
what's the opposite of shunya it is
infinity it is eternity it is
endless creation
it is the very individuated fire working
that is this creation it is the very
love light leela that is at play with
itself
in this creation that is what a void
is so you're avoiding void
avoiding void avoiding
void infinitude nothingness infinitude
nothingness
and these ultimately collapse
into one into the very
ineffable perfection of
this
and the more that you know how to just
relax into that
where you drop the attributes you drop
the describing
drop the symbolization and just
melt relax
surrender
and begin feeling the joy and the peace
of just i am
and those are the gym repetitions
those are the gym repetitions
i am that which avoids
void avoids void
i am that which endlessly
creates infinite possibility in
avoidance of nothingness and emptiness
i am that which uses smoke and
mirrors in delusion of
my love light unity
i am that which uses the illusion
that we've described throughout the show
where
the mind is toiling one around endlessly
seeking peace and happiness externally
in relationship
substances experiences
i am that which uses
that very smoking mirrors that very
delusional
illusional process
for my play
for my very love light unity
leela divine play
that's the forgetting that's the hiding
that's the remembering that's the
seeking
it's the coolest thing the one infinite
creator
can veil itself the veilless veil
it can walk back through the gateless
gate there was never a gate there was
never a veil that was never
a maze there was never an escape room
and yet it very much
so feels like there was a veil there was
a gate
there was a lock there was an escape
room
that's the [ __ ] coolest feature
and to know yourself as that which
creates that feature is so cool
you're not a victim to the creation
you're not a victim to your individuated
firework of infinity
you are the creator of the creation you
are the creator
of the firework of infinity
as siddhar meshwar and sargatatha said
as you think so you are
are you the creator or are you
the victim jim repetition yourself
away from the victim towards the creator
towards the subtlety of the awareness
towards the subtlety of that which
creates even awareness in the realities
and you will regain that spiritual mass
you will regain
the very will and choice and sovereignty
that makes your individuated firework
radiate
like the love and light of the sun
no infinity and no me
i am appearing as endless
costumes
the more that you truly
know and take beyond
just the tastes and the glimpses of
infinity
but truly become anchored
in that realization the more that you
recognize that
you are that which appears as the
endless costumes you
are literally the costume generator
itself
i am the source of infinite possibility
i am the costume generator
i am the form generator i am the
creation generator
i am the love light lila at play with
itself
generator
and i'll never come to the end of all of
my playful exploration
everything we do is to avoid
the nothingness that we are
and we had a great clip on our
channel from the second
round interview with frank
yang eternal bra this one was called
after our first one
called infinite bra and
frank and i had a strong dialectic in
the second one
where we were able to really hone in on
a lot of the most
powerful analogies and essences
of the natural state of the nature of
reality
and so there's a clip on our channel
with
this very title and i highly recommend
watching that
and frank's been a very instrumental
role on my recognizing
on my awakening as well
transcend beyond transcend beyond what
go beyond beyond beyond beyond what
beyond
being and not being beyond the absolute
and the relative beyond birth and death
beyond mystery and knowing beyond here
and there beyond time and timelessness
beyond
space and spacelessness beyond unreal
and real beyond
unmanifested and manifested beyond
nothing and everything beyond void and
infinity beyond dream and reality
beyond natural and unnatural beyond
permanence and
impermanence beyond ego and
enlightenment
beyond nirvana and samsara beyond
to
this
ineffable perfection
your own thought process keeps you
from seeing your already perfection
your very toiling mind
itself is what keeps you from
seeing your already perfection
yogas chitta vritti nirodha use
the breath
to regain spiritual mass to create the
pause to distance oneself
from that toiling mind towards
the relaxation into awareness of
awareness
itself
and recognize the diamond of the peace
and happiness that you already are
creation is entheogenic
and theogen means unleashing god
within unleashing the divine within
it's the entire point healing delusion
that never was
all is the absolute
even the very distorted
egoic contracted energy of
the onion layers of seeking peace and
happiness externally
even that is the absolute now is it
distorted away
from what is the
eradication of the suffering yes
absolutely it itself is suffering it's
catalyzing
suffering for not only the costume but
for
the family around them for the friends
around them for the co-workers for the
community and for the world
and to undergo the process of healing
that delusion that never was
is spirituality which is the realignment
itself
with the one heart and that is the
entire point
which is recognizing the very
entheogenic
nature of your reality which is the
kingdom of god is within
me
luke 17 21 the kingdom of god is within
you
the kingdom of gods within you
you are that i am that we are that
the absolute i and my father are one
john 10 30.
the mystic traditions the yogis the
aphorisms the retreats the books they
all
point to the same one end many paths
one end
the very nature of our creation is
gorgeously entheogenic
and that's why when you take magic
mushrooms
lsd ayahuasca 5mu dmt
when you partake
in the entheogens you become
hyper aware to
the very nature of your reality
you become aware of yourself as the
absolute
and then when you come down you
wonder how do i re-baseline myself
to that state again you already
are it
take these little hacks as
the gym repetitions to become more and
more subtly aware
of awareness of the very formlessness of
the very
creator-ness that you are
and then you don't need to rely on
entheogens
rather your nature is anthogenic
every one of these very inhalations
is ecstasy for the trained
addict for that which
is self-aware
truly
they feel the ecstasy in those very
breaths in that very prana
the very life force itself
ego was lie child was
never unsafe all is god
the very mind toiling us
around feeling unsafety because of some
sort of traumatic
childhood experience all of that
contracted energy
itself feeling
unsafe in your very
own creation was a lie
you were safe the whole time
you are what created the
lockless escape room for yourself
you were never unsafe the very
perversions and twists and distortions
themselves
were a lie they were delusions they were
illusions
and the more rapidly that we recognize
that
the more rapidly that we take a piece of
content
like this and say that i'm done seeking
peace and happiness
in maya in externally i'm going to
100 earnestly
recognize and become aware of awareness
itself
and in doing so what you do is you ramp
that up to your highest desire you put
that in the north star position you give
it all your earnestness and boom it
yields
faster and you become awakened you
become
enlightened
you begin to hear that the background
nectar of music was playing the whole
time but your noisy mind was preventing
you from hearing it
is another way to say this
ego is my top tool in awakening
the source of infinite possibility uses
ego it uses maya it uses these
distortions and delusions the smoke and
mirrors
to awaken us
i as the source of infinite possibility
use
these delusional tools of ego
maya affinity form
addiction attachment craving
aversion validation all of these
twists and kinks in order to create a
pressure cooker
for the drill sergeant of awakening
suffering to come in with the massive
sludge hammer after i have not
listened to the little feather tickles
and
okay okay i'll turn inward i'll
understand the peace and joy of the
nature of my awareness itself
i'll i'll recognize myself as the
creator
it is our top tool in awakening
i am infinite walking all costumes home
after beautiful explorations
the source of infinite possibility
manifests this
beautiful creation
i am that which manifests this beautiful
creation
and then has all costumes
undergo a very delusional illusional
process intoxication by maya
which then drops as our awareness of
awareness
increases
and that's the process of when we start
walking
each other home when maya decreases an
awareness
of awareness increases awareness of
being the one infinite creator increases
we
truly become stewards and shepherds to
each other in the process
of walking each other home in pure
service to others
and that's all after this beautiful very
intoxicative very playful
exploration
one inner changeless
reality
the very parmenidus the very
all change is illusion
the very nothingness void shunya
and then the infinite outer changing
realities
endlessly changing
there's this creation then there's that
creation
and then there's this form and then
there's this costume
and then there's this civilizational
ascensionary dynamic
and then there's this different vehicle
of awareness that doesn't use
nervous systems and then there's
this style of a big bang that leads to a
completely different universe that's not
planets and stars
endless as
heraclitus said ponte rey everything
flows
synthesize heraclitus parmenidus
and go beyond to
ineffable perfection
we
i am the absolute beyond coming
and going appearing like
coming and going still
yourself into ineffable
timeless perfection
so you see the difference between that
there's the coming and going
and then there's going beyond
the coming and going you have to turn
coming and going
itself into an object and transcend it
once you see that very subtle
distinction
you're able to turn the very nature
of nirvana and samsara of coming and
going of birth and death you're able to
turn that
whole thing itself into an object and
transcend it
to beyond
and then relax
into the ineffable perfection
to recognize your true nature
and express yourself is why
we are here the very
nature of our
creation is for us
to fall asleep into
the delusion of maya
and then to shatter through
that illusion to recognize
our true nature and to
express yourself
express yourself baby you're a firework
right infinite eternal
fireworks
that are done most harmonically without
suffering when one has truly
recognized one's true nature
the essence of why we're here
inescapable divinity playing with itself
in dreamed creations
all costumes inescapable
divinity playing with itself
as love light leela
in dreamed creations
we use neurobiology as
a vehicle design to explore realities
this is where the understanding of
science
is very important when you're
only hyper spiritual
you lose the analysis
of form but you really
want to synthesize the very
analysis of form and affinity
of this creation in with your spiritual
knowledge
because when you bring those two things
together you become
way more like a jedi way more
this is why you want to know about
neuroscience you want to know
about biology you want to know about
the beauty of the chemo
electroconnectomics
you want to know about
the very similar way like we talk about
spirituality
as the realignment to the one heart
well the best science is what
realigns pre-pathology
to maximize well-being
so you play with that a little bit and
you're like hmm so
in a sense pathology is like the parable
of the prodigal son
so when you don't address those very
metabolomic pathologies that are
developing
intracellularly what happens
is that the cell itself becomes
pathological
just like in the parable of the prodigal
son if you're not
addressing the mind being toiled around
in maya
what's happening is that there's a lot
of additional suffering that's being
created just like the cell
and so with science when you know how to
address the very pathologies that are
developing at the metabolomic level
as the very imbalance happens you bring
it back
to the aligned state just like with the
purification
as you recognize your true nature you
undergo a process of purifying
of realigning faster and faster with
love light unity leela
rather than with that conditioned onion
layer
so we use neurobiology as a vehicle
designed to explore realities
we've taken eons
in order to land on this beautiful
mind-body
spirit complex that is able to
house the very awareness the very
consciousness the very observation the
very witnessing
itself that is formless
that is able to be the vehicle that we
use
in the dreamed realities in order for us
to
experience them in order for us to
explore them
and over time we will use other tools
we will use other vehicles
we have been and we will eternity
infinity endless creativity
in the oroboros in this creation you
go from a big bang and you go through
the tail through the center of the snake
which right now is really ramping up the
speed at which
intelligence is accelerating especially
with things like artificial
general intelligence let alone evolving
from
a single cell on a planet to the
multi-cell organisms on the planet
but now we're all the way up to an 8
billion person civilization that's
building artificial general intelligence
and indistinguishable virtual realities
and
synthetic biology and neuralink
technologies
and so now the intelligence is really
accelerating until this very
refractionary crescendo
and that's just like that source light
refracting
into the visible light spectrum and then
refracting again
into the visible light spectrum and
ascending like the solenoid
to the attractor itself which is this
very refractionary crescendo
and then you get this very
multiplication of existences
and this is why when you look at things
like the metaverse
you look at the synthesis of agi with
indistinguishable virtual realities with
synthetic biology with neuralink with
all these technologies
what you see is you see this very
refractionary crescendo into a
multiplication of existences
you see the very matrixy nature
that we already are
you're going into the indistinguishable
virtual world for 80 years
that you already are in
and on you go to the next exploration on
you go to the next exploration
i have forgotten and then i remember and
then i hide and then i seek
but you can go beyond coming and going
you can go beyond
hiding and seeking beyond forgetting and
remembering too
everything is about moments of people
in space time that are dreamed
everything is about these eight billion
costumes
having these beautiful fireworky moments
in their love light leela in space time
and it's all dreamed and it's beautiful
but that's what this is creation is
about these 8 billion costumes in
lovelight leela
fireworking and enjoying
that process
what is a dream but a dream within a
dream
what is your dream when you go and dream
at night
what is that dream but a dream within
this already dream
which is a dream within an already dream
and a dream within an already dream and
a dream within an already dream and then
it's turtles
and then you relax
because you are the one infinite creator
you are the source
of all turtles you are the source of
all embedded realities
you are the source you
are the source
our costumes are places to house
perspectives
so the very nature of your costume
is the very nature of how cool it is
for there to be a perspective of the one
infinite creator and when you
expand your awareness beyond even your
own
costumed perspective to all of the
costumed perspectives
and you hold that very all-inclusive
awareness happening on the planetary
level
you become more and more subtly aware of
the love light lila that is happening
and interplaying with
itself very beautifully and you can even
take that all-inclusive awareness
and transcend even that
very last attribute
the very ineffable absolute
that is also this
just know you are visiting dreams
there is only one intelligence there is
only one intelligence you are visiting
dreams
endlessly visiting dreams the one
intelligence
super creative the source of infinite
possibility
immersing itself playfully in dreams
you don't realize your own love story
until your death
you don't realize your own love story
until your death how many stories have
there been
of people all 80 years of their life
never truly feeling their own love story
until the very moment that they're dying
and they go
i haven't lived this whole time i'm only
now
feeling love the true
effortless love of god
the very unconditional celebration
of life of reality
don't wait until death
when you die before you die
what do you get you get the fountain
of bliss and peace that you already
are and you tap into your love story
truly and then every moment
is your love story every breath is your
love story
every experience is your love story
and to know that is to be awakened
the deepest art to
bridge the realization to
those still asleep
the very deepest art
you write the most eloquent poetry
can you create the most beautiful
explanatory documentaries animated
series
can you take the most powerful
one-on-one dialectics that you have
and help point people to their true
nature
it is the deepest art you could call it
precision consciousness
it's beautiful to be able to awaken
to catalyze the ignition of
enlightenment within
other people you become entheogenic
yourself and then butterfly effect out
the very entheogenic
radiance of the sunlight that then
creates
more of the awakening in other costumes
to its true nature
which is exactly what is happening
refine that deepest art
that's exactly what's going on with this
atlas costume right now
is the refining of that deepest art
to become even more jedi-like
even more precise and eloquent
and direct and playful
and peaceful and joyful in the process
like joseph in the coat of many colors
like the chameleon
consciousness shape-shifting across
those that are most egoic to those that
are most enlightened
that's the deepest art
the great
arabic architecture
that are the very sculptures of god the
very sculptures of the absolute
you could call it fractal architecture
mukharnas
and we're really grateful that frank
brought this
onto the program
and we unpacked the very essence
of the avoiding voidness
of it the avoiding voidness
of the mukarna the mukarna is the
fractal architecture that
shows you the avoiding voidness of the
nature of reality
you are the mukharna you are the
avoiding voidness
and this is where you can also go and
watch
the maths town channel
and watch the benoit mandelbrot infinite
fractal zoom
and you can immerse yourself into
the mukharna infinite fractal zoomy
nature of the avoiding voidness
that we are
and we need more architecture like that
across our planet as well
that is one of the core things that
frank and i have been talking about
and as we catalyze the global awakening
we really need more
fractal architecture like that we need
more beautiful digital visualizations of
the natural state
and so we'll be unleashing more of that
soon
infinity's fireworks don't need
to validate or comparatively judge
each other's beauty
stop looking at other fireworks of
infinity other costumes and seeking
their validation
stop comparatively judging your firework
to their fireworks it's all infinite
fireworks you're the creator of the
infinite fireworks
so just become at peace
and joy with your unique firework
and all of the costumes unique fireworks
that is all
cool and this was the most recent post
which is the
the clip from the round
to interview with frank where
we unpacked the
very everything we do
is to avoid the nothingness that we
are
and i highly recommend watching this
clip
and i highly recommend checking out
mukharnas
arabic architectural visualizations of
god
so go and give that a look and that is
all
that is it
it's a great set
we'll definitely make sure to
continue as we do these
drops of 40 or so graphics
that we will do this process of
doing a video like this which
then deepens the
metaphysical analysis of those
almost 40 graphics and
by doing that process it both helps
the atlas costume refine its
metaphysical distillation
synthesis and communication and yet also
the
these other costumes for them to
be able to leverage
this medium of further distilling it
on video and then to gain the
further realizations from
that process so if it brought you value
i would love for you to like the video
which helps the algorithm
if you haven't yet subscribe to the
channel also
share the video with those that you feel
like it would resonate with
greatly and i would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below
drop us a comment and let us know how
these resonated with you which ones you
liked the most which ones
you liked the least which ones that you
found funny which ones you found
playful which ones you found serious
which ones most resonated with you which
ones did not resonate with you
and let us know why we would love
to get the community talking more in the
comments
with one another in the process of
ascending
and purifying reflecting the true nature
and if you want a deeper experience with
that process
of ascending and reflecting and
purifying together
you can join the simulation club
the link is in the bio below
and that is all i adore you
infinitely thank you very grateful
thank you
and really
take some time to dive in deeper
onto this avoiding void
avoiding void avoiding void
infinity nothingness infinity
nothingness
the very nature of
this ineffable
perfection
thank you
uh
wow
[Music]
you